and welcome to hannity and we begin
tonight with the fox news alert wow what
a day in the washington sewer and swamp
once again while you the american people
you know the people that actually make
this a great country are facing you know
a deluge of serious problems you know
like record inflation record high gas
prices record numbers of illegal
immigrants record homicides and so many
of our towns and cities all the swamp
creatures on capitol hill they were busy
with yet another anti-trump kangaroo
court and show trial where the outcome
as we've been telling you has been and
remains predetermined has been that way
since day one instead of honest hearings
on how to protect our institutions our
elected officials to protect the
people's house the capital instead of
ever allowing riots like those that
occurred in the summer of 2020 from ever
ever happening again we see nothing but
blind never-ending
rage
what is a seemingly an
obsessive-compulsive cult
like rage against donald trump never
ends now clearly trump haters for them
january 6 is just another excuse to
smear donald trump anyone who supports
them this is not about safety and
security and securing the capital or
getting to the truth this has never been
about having a fair and serious hearing
and proceeding so we can come up with
solutions today we heard more rumors a
ton of hearsay and wow a lot of
impeached uh testimony that we'll get to
in a second and this is why it's never
hearsay is never admissible in a real
court of law including this wild claim
from a former low-level white house
staffer watch this
the president said something to the
effect of
i'm the effing president
take me up to the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm said sir you
need to take your hand off the steering
wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle and mr when mr
ornato had recounted this story to me he
had motioned towards his clavicles
what you heard there is an incredibly
bizarre hearsay allegation from a person
who according to our sources was
was actually prepared she wanted to work
for donald trump outside the white house
when he wasn't president at mar-a-lago
and according to people that i talked to
tonight until others advised the former
president not to hire her in other words
according to the federalist and people i
spoke to after january the sixth she
wanted to work for donald trump that bad
person she's now testifying against and
now get this according to nbc by the way
abc is reporting that fox news is
reporting reporting it nbc's peter
alexander we have confirmed it here at
fox quote a source close to the secret
service is telling me both bobby engel
the lead agent and the presidential
limousine driver are both prepared to
testify under oath under the threat of
perjury that neither man was ever
assaulted
and that mr trump then president never
lunged for the steering wheel a perfect
example of why hearsay is not allowed in
a real court of law today the so-called
witness also claimed president trump
wanted to get rid of the metal detectors
at the january 6 rally and allow armed
individuals to attend today president
trump flat out denied this claim and
pointed out a simple fact
zero guns were ever discharged by those
that breached the capitol or in d.c that
day according to so many so-called
journalists in the media mob it was
hyperventilating again oh we we got him
again this time trump prussia collusion
oh we got him let's impeach him anyway
they said this was a game changer wrong
again
the january 6th select committee wrapped
up a stunning public hearing it was we
should make no mistake one for the
history books and a complete game
changer only 25 or 26 years old cassidy
hutchinson
exploded
the lies and the myths that the trump
team have been perpetuating
for more than a year now
this is an historic day our descendants
are going to
ask us what we know about cassidy
hutchinson that's a name that they will
know
they're going to ask
us what this was like to watch this and
to listen to this because this is a day
that
is going to loom very large in american
history one last thing big picture
liz cheney began her final comments by
saying that we are in debt to cassidy
hutchinson i think america and democracy
is in debt to this young woman
oh really just take a word for it she
wasn't even there hearsay witness sound
familiar oh that was the other
impeachment trial now amid all the
anti-trump glee the media mob and this
committee continues to hide several very
pertinent important pivotal facts
involving all of this first president
trump already faced a congressional
investigation and impeachment over
january 6th he was acquitted second
biden's inspector general for the dod
also investigated trump's dod and their
response to january 6 and guess what
they found zero wrongdoing and third
right here on this program we have
confirmed that on january the 4th 2021
during a meeting at the oval office
featuring president trump chief of chief
of staff mark meadows acting defense
secretary chris miller and the
department of defense chief of staff
cash patel who will join us tonight and
also the chairman of the joint chiefs
mark milley well the president re
authorized as is required by law up to
20 000 national guard troops be made
available for security at the capitol
again as the law requires then of course
that becomes the jurisdiction of nancy
pelosi and muriel bowser now four of the
individuals in that meeting have
confirmed all of this on camera that the
security request in fact took place
interesting for a guy that wants to
start or initiate some type of coup
uh that he would be authorizing twenty
thousand troops to prevent any trouble
take a look
calling up the guard and then it became
at the chain of command went to nancy
pelosi and to the mayor of d.c muriel
bowser did you as required by law
authorize that
uh 100
and attested to by many people and they
turned it down nancy pelosi turned it
down mayor bowser's written refusal the
communications between the leader of the
capitol police and their chain of
command to the dod refusing our request
to allow national guardsmen and women to
stage on january 4 and 5 before january
6. did you both ask for the national
guard to be called up
without a doubt sean uh we've made that
very clear not just once but on numerous
occasions we wanted to make sure that
there was plenty of national guard on
the ready
in case there was some kind of violence
i had a meeting with president trump on
the third of january concerning some
international threats and at the very
end he asked if there were any requests
for national guard support what was the
president's response to you with regard
to the request made by mayor bowser
fill it and do whatever was necessary to
protect the
demonstrators
and chris miller on this program
confirmed that
two of the four
that uh were in the room
actually testified before the committee
and told the january six committee this
so why would president trump make the
request if he wanted the capital to be
breached that day two days beforehand
why would d.c mayor bowser in writing
and nancy pelosi refused to call up the
guard it's her domain she's in charge of
capital security and by the way donald
trump made the troops fully
available he fully authorized as
required by law by the president
they made the choice it was their
jurisdiction to call them up not donald
trump's you may remember remember that
from the summer of 2020. why did the
house sergeant-at-arms and the senate
sergeant-at-arms why did they deny the
capital police chief's request for
national guard six separate times and by
the way why won't anyone on this
so-called january 6 committee ask any of
these questions why have they not
demanded the emails the texts the phone
records of pelosi of bowser the sergeant
of arms in the house and the senate the
capitol police chief and chuck schumer
who got a letter on uh january 5th
saying the intel is saying we might have
violence they haven't brought any of
these people in of course this is not a
real committee looking for real answers
it's a political theater conducted
exclusively only by people who already
voted to impeach donald trump every
single person on this committee every
you can't make it up every one of them
voted to impeach donald trump and by the
way some didn't want to certify the
elections of either donald trump or
george bush this is why they would not
allow congressman jim jordan or
congressman banks on this committee for
democrats the media mob this is really
little more than what a fun distraction
from their bleak political prospects liz
cheney what one final hurrah at the
bitter end of a sad and self-serving
political career partnering with the
very people that called her own father
let's see a war criminal uh a murderer a
crook with halliburton if lawmakers if
they really wanted to conduct righteous
oversight protect our country they might
want to look into the current president
who's been selling access to our
government for years now you wouldn't
know it from watching fake news cnn or
msdnc or any of the networks but joe
biden you know he works in the mostly in
the fake oval office it seems not trump
and a newly uncovered audio reveals that
your president joe biden knew all about
his son's sketchy foreign business
ventures for example in china we now
have a 2018 voicemail you can hear joe's
voice you know it's him he mentions a
new york times article about hunter's
deal with the so-called spy chief of
china tells his son that he thinks he's
in the clear listen to this
hey palace dad it's 8 15. um
on wednesday night because the chance
can be call nothing urgent
i just want to talk to you i thought the
article at least has been on online
that's going to be printed 21 times it's
good
and you can clear
and uh
anyway um
if you get a chance give me a call i
love you
all right that was 2018. he's running
for president 2020 and he was asked over
and over again and repeated over and
over again that he never one time not
once ever spoke to hunter biden about
his foreign business dealings at all you
might remember we have the tape take a
look
mr vice president how many times have
you ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings i've never
spoken to my son about his overseas
ministers i have never discussed with my
son or my brother or anyone else
anything having to do with their
businesses period
and what i will do is the same thing we
did
in our administration there will be an
absolute wall between personal and
private
uh and and the government do you stand
by your statement that you did not
discuss any of your son's overseas
business yes i stand by that statement
now we even have pictures of joe and
hunter and all those foreign business
partners joe met them where's that
investigation joe biden was straight up
lying to our faces he did it over and
over and over again and it's clear from
hunter's laptop from hell that joe
profited and why by the way is this why
joe doesn't want to lift tariffs on
china because they have them compromised
hunter made a fortune is this why joe
biden approve vladimir putin's
nordstream 2 pipeline while
simultaneously canceling the keystone xl
pipeline because hunter made a fortune
from a russian oligarch
the media mob the democratic party they
don't care at one bit in fact they don't
care really about the corruption the
lying the dishonesty or real quid pro
quos or the violence in the summer of
2020 because they can't use it to bash
their political opponents it's that
simple have you ever asked yourself why
there's never been a committee to
investigate all of those peaceful riots
500 and what 74 of them in the summer of
2020 dozens of dead americans thousands
of injured police officers billions in
property damage
where where's that committee a federal
courthouse attacked every single night
for months in portland a police precinct
in minnesota burned to the ground
historic st john's church next to the
white house lit a blaze they don't seem
to care about any of it why because it
doesn't help them politically they can't
use it to bash donald trump one more
time for good old fun the media dc
politicians were either silent about
those riots or didn't want to anger
their left-wing radical base so they
either were silent or they lied to us
and said they were mostly peaceful and
we know they weren't or they just
outright encouraged it like kamala
harris did by promoting that bail fund
for rioters to get him out of jail and
telling the mob that listen they
shouldn't stop they're not going to stop
they won't stop we're not going to stop
and you need to take note you need to be
where
where are those hearings into
574 riots in 2020 and while we're at it
where are the hearings about quid and
pros and quotes especially the one with
joe you know you're not getting the
billion dollars unless you fire the
prosecutor that
is investigating my son who's making
millions without any experience at all
apparently democrats the media mob were
so outraged over
donald trump's quid pro quo that didn't
exist but they ignored the real quid pro
quo you might recall
we're not going to give you the billion
dollars
they said you have no authority you're
not the president the president said i
said call him
i said i'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars
i said you're not getting the billion
i'm going to be leaving here and i think
it was about six hours i look as i'm
leaving in six hours if the prosecutor's
not fired you're not getting the money
oh son of a [ __ ]
got fired
son of a bee they fired him
all i asked for is i all i do is offer
to withhold a billion dollars that's a
quid and a pro and a quote by joe
remember the media mob democrats accused
trump of russia collusion they lied for
three long years turns out the only real
rush of collusion was hillary rodham
clinton's dirty misinformation bought
and paid for dirty russian dossier the
media mob and the democrats then lied on
the eve of the 2020 election and they
claimed without one shred of evidence oh
no this hunter biden laptop it's all
it's all russian misinformation a
complete and total lie
everything they accuse trump of they are
guilty of demagoguery rules the day
inside this modern
really strange really radical democratic
socialist party but now with massive
policy failures at home and abroad their
days in power are likely numbered and
actions always speak louder than words
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else